hello and welcome to the next video when
the Bitcoin protocol video miniseries
this video is going to be covering the
transactions section in the Bitcoin
paper if you don't have the Bitcoin
paper its Bitcoin org slash Bitcoin dot
PDF if you're just now joining us I
highly suggest you start with the first
video which covers the abstract and then
hit the introduction then hit the this
current video which is based on
transactions so this is about how can we
actually have these transactions but
then it ends with presenting the next
problem which will be of course solved
in the next section so this section
starts with we define an electronic coin
as a chain of digital signatures each
owner transfers the coin to the next by
digitally signing a hash of the previous
transaction and the public key of the
next owner and adding these to the end
of the coin a payee
can verify the signatures to verify the
chain of ownership now just keep in mind
this is just verifying the chain of
ownership so here we have our first
definition of a coin right and what a
coin is and a transfer of a coin is done
by a digital signature in the form of a
hash and hash was taught to you in the
abstract video so it's a hash of the
previous transaction the public key of
the next owner and then adding this to
the end of the coin and so this is
obviously a chain of these digital
signatures now here the only part I see
people tripping up on is going to be you
know besides hash which has already been
covered though in the abstract video is
this notion of a public key so what is a
public key well whenever you hear public
key that means the person if it's at
least in the sense of encryption this
person is referring to a symmetrical
encryption system and so in asymmetrical
encryption you have two separate keys
where you've got a private key and
you've got a public key these keys are
different but they are going to be
linked map
matically I'm not gonna go into
explaining that but for now we'll leave
it there the public key is used to
actually encrypt data where the private
key is gonna be used to decrypt any data
or to create a digital signature so it's
gonna be a very private thing and this
is why you can sign something and and
why it's called the digital signature
because it's yours so at the end of all
of this as someone being paid in Bitcoin
you can put you can verify that the
person who is paying you in Bitcoin has
actually acquired that Bitcoin and they
did or do own it and you can certain you
verify this by searching for their
public key signature at the end of that
coins digital you know signatures right
so there are a list of digital
signatures now comes the kicker though
so let's get back to the paper the
problem of course is the payee can't
verify that one of the owners or the
current one of course did not double
spend the coin a common solution is to
introduce a trusted central authority or
a mint that checks every transaction for
double spending after each transaction
the coin must be returned to the mint to
issue a new coin and only coins issued
directly from the mint are trusted not
to be double spent the problem with the
solution is that the fate of the entire
money system depends on the company
running the mint with every transaction
having to go through them just like a
bank so the problem is not only is the
most recent quote-unquote owner able to
double to spend that coin at multiple
entities at this point so so they could
so you they might you know pay you in
this coin you look at it you look okay
yeah this person owns this coin but
let's just stop them from going to five
other people and being like hey I want
to pay with this coin right so at this
point still being able to show that hey
I own this coin if this process was
allowed to continue and multi people
along the way could have double spent
that coin this would obviously be
multiplying the monetary supply I mean
can you guys imagine a monetary system
where money was like literally being
multiplied through use I mean how crazy
would that be oh right right
fractional-reserve banking system that
we use right now silly me
so anyway generally the answer is to
introduce a third party here and this
third party's tasked with confirming
that each transaction is legit and it's
like not a form of a double expenditure
and then when confirmed what they do is
they issue a quote-unquote new and and
here they say coin ER but really what
happens is they issue a new dollar and
then in bitcoins case this would be a
coin and then all the only trusted
version of money is the one that came
from the central authority but of course
as discussed in the abstract in the
introduction the problem here inherently
is that we require a central authority
to do this where every transaction must
go through them so moving on in the
paper we need a way for the payee to
know that the previous owners did not
sign any earlier transactions for our
purposes the earliest transaction is the
one that counts
so we don't care about later attempts to
double spend now this is really
important the idea here is that the
first expenditure is the only one that
needs to be tracked as all the other
other ones are fraudulent but of course
you know how do we know which one comes
first but mostly we just need to
understand that the idea of the system
is that the first one is the real one
the only way to confirm the absence of a
transaction is to be aware of all
transactions in the mint based model the
mint is all was aware of all
transactions and decided which arrive
first to accomplish accomplish this
without a trusted party transactions
must be publicly announced and we need a
system for participants to agree on a
single history of the order in which
they were received the payee needs proof
that at the time of each transaction the
majority of nodes agree that this is the
first received okay so slightly long
here but pretty basic concepts covered
so here we first want to confirm that
the absence of a transaction rights we
want to know there's no previous version
of the
transaction that's already been done in
the case of a central authority they
usually have a massive ledger though
this is not a public ledger so to make
it work with this system we would need
all transactions to be publicly
broadcast and then we actually need
another system where the participants of
this network agree on a single history
of the order in which transactions were
done the payee
needs proof at the time of the
transaction the majority of the nodes in
the network agree that this is indeed
the first transaction of its kind so the
way that the payee
can be proved that can prove this is
when everyone shares this massive ledger
the person can ask basically ask the
network hey is this the first one so now
in the form of how will we actually do
transactions we have an answer right no
sadly this answer needs more work
because we do not need a way to verify
that the transaction or we do I'm sorry
because we do need a way to verify the
transaction has not been done already so
for this we have a proposal here as was
in the abstract for this time server
which is the hash-based time server that
we discussed in the abstract and that's
what will actually be covering in the
next video so hopefully you guys are all
up to speed here if I've been unclear on
anything feel free to leave a comment or
a question below as always thanks for
watching things for all of the support
in the subscriptions and until the next
video